he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the law
even his prayer shall be what
an abomination
the bible has abominations
and it has sins
now they're all sins
but an abomination
is
an intense
sin
without offending anyone let me give an
example
a man and a woman
coming together
for physical relations who are not
married
that is sin in the eyes of god
and if not confessed
will result in the loss of the soul
but a man
and a man coming together
that is also sin but that's a step
further that is abomination because it
goes contrary to the laws of nature the
man and the woman outside of marriage
yes it's sin but as still it is still a
natural act are you following what i'm
saying it is sin with a natural act it
is sin but a man and a man a woman and a
woman a man and an animal
[Music]
that is abomination
now
keep this in mind listen to proverbs 28
9 he that turneth away his ear
not someone who's ignorant someone who
says don't tell me i don't want to know
i couldn't care less he or she who does
that even that person's prayer shall be
an abomination in the eyes of god
and some of us in church we practice
that
as i said earlier we know there's some
things we ought to do things we ought to
make right since to forgive uh sins to
apologize for and we absolutely refuse
but we go to god in prayer and our
prayers arise before god as a stench in
his nostrils he that turneth away his
ear in second peter chapter 3 verse 5
the bible says for this they willingly
are ignorant of
many years ago i was conducting an
evangelistic series in the city of
detroit
close to where i live that's my home
airport
three weeks we met every night this lady
came the first week
and she came she was blessed
then i did not see her at the beginning
of week number two so i called her on
her job and i said sister whomever
i didn't see you
you know what she said to me
she said elder skeet i cannot keep
coming
because if i keep coming and sit under
that preaching
i will have to make a decision
so i am not coming back
now that's honestly you must respect
but that's a well-spoken form of
self-destruction i am not coming back
because if i do
that word will cause me to make a
decision and i'm not ready for that
based on where i am in my life he that
turneth away his ear
from hearing the law because often in
the bible the word law does not only
mean the ten commandments it means the
revealed will of god
he that turneth away his ear
you know you ought to return a tithe and
you do not
this text does not embrace those who are
ignorant
acts 17 verse 30 and the times of this
ignorance god went at john 15 22 if i
had not come and spoken unto them they
had not had sin we are talking about
those who deliberately do not want to
know in the eyes of god ignorance must
have two qualities quality number one i
did not know quality number two i had no
way of knowing that is ignorance in
god's eyes this does not qualify for
those in second peter 3 5 for this they
willingly are ignorant of it does not
cover the arrogant ones in proverbs 28 9
he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the law
the will of god
even his prayer
shall be abomination
there are some people who tell you don't
tell me anything about the health
message i like my meat
don't bother me with the health message
i like my meat
was talking to me some while ago about
an elder
in some church
and the elder said someone had preached
on health
the health of the church said no one
will take my meat from
me well fine
no one will take my meat from me now
biblically how you eat affects your
character
it is not by accident that the very
first victory christ won was a victory
of appetite what he would consume of
course he avoided food his victory was
over appetite the first adam fell on the
very same point this is not accidental
it is not accidental that daniel begins
with a story on diet
this elder said no one
will take my meat from me
he that turneth away his ear
from hearing the law
even his prayer
shall be an abomination
there is always
but
let me pray again father continue to
instruct me in what to say and how to
say it and when
in jesus name i pray amen
we sabotage our own prayers
it's not god
god is a god who sent christ surely is
willing to give you tuition
but how do you compare christ if god
will give me christ why wouldn't he give
me tuition are you following me if
christ if god will send christ someone
equal with himself the creator and
sustainer of heaven and earth why would
he not heal a cold or whatever
but there's always a but
psalm 66 verse 18. go there with me
psalm 66
verse 18.
so by the way i recommended john i also
recommend psalms if you want to
experience the full range of human
emotions read the psalms
read the psalms you see the humanity
of those who wrote the psalms most were
written by david but other people wrote
some
same with proverbs solomon wrote most
other people wrote psalm 66 verse 18
if i regard iniquity in my heart finish
the verse
the lord
will not hear me now what does that mean
if i not if i commit outwardly sin if i
regard
iniquity let me give an example
there are some people who say
i have no problem
with people who smoke occasionally now i
don't smoke
but i have no problem with those who do
from time to time on your birthday and
thanksgiving and valentine's day that's
fine
you are regarding iniquity in your heart
[Music]
i have no problem
with uh
those who
go to the games on sabbath
and go fishing on sabbath and go
snorkeling on sabbath i i have no
problem i don't do it but i have no
problem
you don't have to do it
to be classified as part of it
i didn't say that clearly let me try to
clarify by using the bible
in matthew 23 jesus condemns the scribes
and pharisees hypocrites
you got you build the tomb of the
prophets of the s
the saints and garnish the chapucker of
the prophets and you say if we had been
in the days of our fathers we would not
have been partakers with them in the
blood of the prophets if they're saying
we didn't live back then we didn't do it
jesus says fill thee up then the measure
of your fathers in other words you are
as guilty as they are even though you
did not do it because their attitude
towards old testament prophets is your
attitude towards me and i'm a prophet
this is a very serious uh concept
you do not have to physically commit the
murder for god to regard you as a
murderer you simply have to have the
same
mindset you regard murder in your heart
or i
and so the bible says he if i regard
iniquity in my heart
the lord
will not hear me
so you can pray
and fast
and ask other people to pray for you
but there is a blockage
there is a blockage preventing the
transmission of god's goodness to you
and your prayer to god why that sin
there is always
but